yeah welcome to this video I'm playing
and culiacan oh yeah this is a frequent
opponent and good score here against
this guy nine and a half a lot of 12 so
some Dublin he had said to him I mean if
you are correct i could rip off your
shadow wood g5 really oh okay so you a
castle you probably i don't i don't
really know that line 93-95 a certain
defined for black
or is it the fifth I don't know maybe I
can go Quincy one and then a quick look
to you one yeah not sure I don't know
that line really okay if I take now
isn't that love something I can take and
check in check and then looked you one
this will be slightly annoying for black
I wonder if I am no we just goes back uh
huh that's interesting didn't expect
that move okay at least rookie one is
very safely prevented I wonder if Knight
c3 is even right here yeah maybe the
slight edge that I have in this position
it's really just very little but it is
some based on the am a little bit easier
position for I have a I have a better
position for my queen here compared to
black I'm trying this here the ideas
then on a 6 i'm going to look the born
and then he has to go to e8 i believe
and then I go back to d4 I'd just want
to make sure that you couldn't get in
Queen to c7 this kind of idea I wonder
actually if 94 is any good maybe yes
maybe yes i can do Knight e5 and then
trying to use the weekend c6 square the
long run I does he have a five year I
don't
I actually didn't think so anyway but so
I'm 95 or not nice cover I can just do
this first quite clear what he does if
I've hmmm maybe maybe it looks a bit
weakening that move but well after night
situ it's not clear what his next move
is actually ok it prevents before but
now I'm having 95 yeah so let's go go in
there and see how he continues from here
slightly annoying to play this position
as black I was thinking Knight g4 here
actually or if i take it hmm rights
knight c6 s also move Knight takes
Knight X and it's not it's not that much
and I wonder about 95 this is an idea
let's do it yeah I hope to provoke that
i'm not sure if it really helps much but
ok i'm going to f3 i guess i look t6 or
night over to d5 I guess the night over
to the five is better what was C for by
the way c-46 is also not bad
so I have provoked some weaknesses in
this camp now look the sexist idea yep
prevented that let's see just double on
the D file while it's got 94 okay I'm
preventing 94 and see if I can play
group d to loop the one you cannot play
b5 as a five hangs so this is good still
not sure I hoped it to assess anything
here okay see what is unprotected this
is a bit worrisome but I see no tech
tech currently so rube t6 was irritating
enough that he decided to retreat okay I
mean let's do this just make sure that
p5 is not hitting my knight on f3 it's
not so great this would be a huge
improvement if I could could activate
that night I don't see how though don't
see how I'm not sure if this is leading
to anything
okay so you've got that duration and
click now and go night each form and I
said unsure if it really needs me much
so once to be form then maybe get that
bag over to d5 or something like that or
is it possible to do something the
threatening won't be three maybe so
let's do here now I need to get the
night back down neither on each form
I've reconned him a little bit but it's
not Oh overlook the tactic hmmm that's
bad I can take five maybe okay 93 ok
let's to let's take then time morning
queen bee five giving up this it's no
good
I can that's impossible without the
night I guess hmm what did I do wrong
okay when i blundered a 4-bit we thought
i had excellent control in this game and
what's up making slow progress but not
didn't lead to anything a case giving
back one pawn
and read still not okay night at five or
96 don't know let's do this okay would
be okay with the draw can I do more 98 I
mean I think I can play that move
without risking anything much no I know
it's a drawer of game drugs are you
trying to win home I don't know I think
I'm just much worse stand still yeah the
engine is on minus two I don't quite get
why he accepts the draw I'm even down on
time okay well it really looked like a
half a little something all the way but
I never got anywhere really oky blunder
day for was okay this one yeah it's
probably not not a good idea now it's
difficult already an eye day for my only
son I'd be three I didn't see nine a
forward it's already a bit a bit awkward
probably I should then do something else
here in this position this is what the
computer wants to do Queenie for or
queen see one moves like that not quite
hey rook h1 yes why not yeah I've got
the H file open that's not bad actually
it's not so bad okay the engines have
zero point forward that feels like I can
work with and with something may be here
the compounds to do this rook h1 look
aged aid and this is kind of okay I mean
like this right here why does a bit a
little bit bad i am hit this oh sorry
the weekend square CI a-- f 5 and so on
it's not much but yeah after I'd lund at
the porn i think im just much worse you
know this is probably a mistake he
didn't need to give it back but it
wasn't wasn't bad it wasn't a bad
decision yeah i think he can can just
continue him this is even though this is
a move by the way yeah black was winning
maybe he yeah well he lost many games
against me from before maybe he was very
cautious there okay thanks for watching